[Music]
welcome aboard TV lovers I'm your host
and captain Liana Galera and this is
ship worthy the only show devoted to
celebrating TV's top couples now like
you I am a passionate TV fan who
connects with the characters I watch
each week and I often find myself
becoming personally invested in their
on-screen romances I'm weird I'm a
weirdo so I wanted to create a space
where fellow shippers can come and gush
with me about their favorite pairings
now in each episode of shift worthy I'll
be doing a fun deep dive into one of my
favorite TV relationships and today it's
time to voyage over to the mysterious
town of Riverdale because we're talking
all about Betty Cooper and Jughead Jones
aka thug head love you in addition to
fangirling over the couple's cutest and
steamiest moments and a fun segment call
it a naughty or nice I'm bringing you
exclusive and never-before-seen
interviews with Lily Reinhart and Cole
Sprouse dishing behind-the-scenes
secrets about their favorite bug head
moments
I love bug head I love our all their
moments and to make matters even more
smoothie lily and Cole are also
romantically linked in real life too so
let's get started and take a look back
at how this Riverdale romance first
sailed across our screen and Anchors
Away
now Betty Cooper may have had a crush on
the boy next door when Riverdale first
premiered but her feelings soon shifted
over to Archie's brooding best friend
with the Southside roots Jughead Jones
you guys mean join us yes but only if
you're tweeting so just what was it that
brought these two ridiculously
attractive characters together in season
1 was it their shared love of sleeping
those late nights working on the blue
and gold or perhaps just the endless
supply of milkshakes at pops I don't
know but I do know that when Jughead
pulled a page from Shakespeare's
romantic playbook in episode 6 and said
this hey Juliet I was absolutely hooked
nautical pun totally intended oh my gosh
and can we please just take a moment to
relive that fantastic first kiss
right now I love a good spontaneous
smooch but I think the most smoothly
part about this scene is just how it
triggered by these natural Nancy Drew
tendencies and jugs reaction was just
too cute Wow
that's what you're thinking about in the
middle of our moment from that point on
in season 1 we were treated to super fun
comic book inspired dream sequences a
few tears and plenty of PDB that's
public displays of bug-head obviously
and bug heads romance fully bloomed in
the season 1 finale with this
heart-melting
milestone
[Music]
I love you okay I still get all the
romantic feels when i rewatch that scene
especially when later evolved into this
sultry makeout sesh now there's no
denying Betty and Jughead chemistry is
off the charts so when I caught up with
Lily on the Riverdale set at the
beginning of season 2 the blonde beauty
gave me the inside scoop on what it's
really like to film those particularly
intimate moments take a look this do get
romantic when Betty and drugged head do
get to see each other when you have to
film those more intimate scenes what is
it like for you as an actor to do that I
feel like it's very comfortable at this
point I mean it's the CW you're not
getting too crazy it's just like I mean
well that shower scene between ya know
that was definitely pretty spicy but um
I haven't had to do that thus far yeah
right but I mean I think we're all so
comfortable with one another and that
it's it's not even really a thing you
know we have a kissing scene it's fine
we don't really think twice about it
when you know characters have to kiss
it's a little different and you're like
wow okay what's this but you know it's
easy we're all friends
it would be more nerve-wracking if you
had to make out with someone that you
didn't know yeah you know exact so if by
chance we do end up like having to kiss
each other it's it's fine and it doesn't
feel weird
you can call get along well you get
along guys are doing pretty good we're
doing good I think good is the
understatement of the year did you guys
see how absolutely perfect
they looked together at the 2018 Met
Gala and their social media pages are
always filled with adorable little nods
to each other
hashtag relationship goals yeah but
regardless of their real-life romance
Lilly and Cole have brought us some
seriously swoon worthy on-screen moments
as Betty and Jughead which leads us into
since this is our first time sailing
together let me break this down we all
know that it takes more than just the
sexy scenes for phantoms to root for a
TV couple it's also those subtle moments
that tug on our heartstrings and keep us
invested in the end game
so in naughty or nice I'm highlighting
my favorite sultry and sweet scenes that
made me fall head over heels for bug
head for example that bug head I love
you is definitely one of my top nice
moments and their post le makeout sesh
well that was naughty and all the right
ways get it got it good here we go
kicking things off in the nice list is
one of my all-time favorite bug head
scenes and it's from episode 10 the Lost
Weekend
aka when Betty threw Jughead a birthday
party happy birthday dear Chuck hey now
I loved the scene in pops when Betty
first opened up to Jughead about her
internal demons there's this darkness in
me that's overwhelming sometimes
and his reaction nearly brought tears to
my eyes it was such a simple yet
protective gesture and it just really
solidified why they're such a good pair
and I also loved this moment from
episode 8 when Betty showed her
unwavering faith and Jughead I believed
you and of course some of my other
favorite smooches include the baby
shower kiss that unforgettable
hand-holding scene and this emotional
moment and Pop's melted my heart you are
a sight for sore eyes
[Music]
but in my opinion one of the nicest
relationship milestones for bug head was
in the season 2 finale when juggy asked
his girl a very important question now
that is what I felt about me my queen
and with that bedroom rendezvous in the
five seasons let's switch over to the
couple's top naughty scenes now who else
was blushing just a little when Betty
and jugg were scantily dressed and
sharing those sheets fangs up if you
agree serpents yeah and of course we
can't talk about naughty scenes without
mentioning dark Betty when she stepped
out of the bathroom rocking that wig for
Jughead
I might have to punish you his reaction
was priceless and it sure sounded like
they had a good time I date
but I still think that the steamiest bug
had seen was the couple's first time
together and guess what
that moment was lily and Cole's favorite
scene to shoot together as well now take
a look at this never-before-seen
interview what was your favorite bug
head seemed to shoot with coal I'm
trying to think of some cute bug head
moment so the first half of season 2
Betty and Jughead were kind of apart for
a lot of it and then their eventual
reunion was one of my favorites to shoot
in the trailer yeah to be honest when I
think it was such a sweet moment after
Betty and Jughead we're together that he
comes home and she's coming into the
Cooper house and you know before she
discovers the dead body on her floor
you know the moment where she's kind of
like in the afterglow that's was kind of
one of my favorite moments the most real
moments I love all their moments it was
amazing
now overall I think the reason why I
love Betty and Jughead so much as a
couple is because no matter what tears
them apart or whatever kind of chaos
rolls into Riverdale they always have
each other's best interests at heart
and they find their way back to each
other plus it doesn't hurt that they
have crazy hot chemistry I'm surprised
for you that does it for this first
bug-head episode of ship worthy but
don't worry as I continue to interview
Lily Reinhardt and Cole Sprouse we'll be
back with follow up episodes about Betty
and Jughead and where their relationship
will be sailing to next so get excited
for that now if you guys enjoyed our
maiden voyage together be sure to give
this video a like and hit subscribe on e
t--'s youtube channel then drop anchor
in the comments below and tell me why
you love Betty and Jughead as a couple
oh and what were your all-time favorite
naughty or nice moments I'm dying to
know
Plus if you strongly ship any other TV
couples tell me comment or tweet me with
your nominations of who you think I
should feature in future episodes of
ship worthy and of course why you love
them as a couple now thank you guys so
much for sailing with me
first episode of ship worthy and until
next time bon voyage TV lovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]